[Music]  when you understand that every single  cell can has the capacity to connect to  the original source of life  you will become a gravitational force  that you cannot imagine the power of you  will draw to yourself everything  that you could possibly dream of to  manifest a reality that you don't think  you're worthy of yet you will be a  gravitational force that will bring in  so much goodness to you so much capacity  for rebirth  so much capacity for forgiveness for  yourself that you can start to live in  the resonance of gratitude for the fact  that you are animated in the human body  right now the tipping point not of a  planet not of a species of the tipping  point of a universe that wants to  resonate at a better harmony we are  about to uplevel the orchestra in this  universe